our companies face more political
interference this year after the
election of Donald Trump and the brexit
vote that's the key finding of the
annual antitrust report published today
by Freshfields one of the world's
leading law firms it argues there is a
growing risk of political intervention
in cross-border deals and potentially a
more protectionist approach to global
trade in goods and services deirdre trap
is a partner in Freshfields antitrust
competition and trade practice so why do
you have these concerns
well we've produced this survey for a
number of years ian and in past years
our themes were around convergence
cooperation collaboration amongst
antitrust agency there are a hundred and
forty of those now worldwide but this
year we do see a change post breaks it
and with the election of President
president-elect Trump given the signals
that he's been sending obviously your
earlier commentators were speaking about
his his very interesting remarks over
the weekend and I think that really
plays up the sorts of things that are of
interest to us so as a businessman we
would expect Donald Trump to be actually
quite pro-business and consolidation and
transaction and so forth but clearly
he's got some hot spots as you they well
they are very interesting aren't they I
mean we've heard a number of times I
think about defense procurement for
instance he's clearly got a thing about
about Air Force one and how much that
cost the Americans but I think it's
slightly wider than that you know during
the election process he was talking
about the time warner AT&T deal so we
can I think anticipate concerns in the
media area drug makers are the much does
he know and and auto I think the auto
industry is very interesting because of
course that also plays into trade in a
big way his comments that you know 35%
tariff on on cars coming into the states
that weren't made there I think a quite
a strong signal of the sorts of things
that are going to be of interest to him
what about foreign investors investing
into the United States and Britain is
the largest overseas investor in the US
do you think UK companies will face more
regulatory scrutiny well potentially but
I doubt actually that the UK the UK
companies are the ones really in the
line of fire in the u.s. they have a
system under the control of a committee
foreign investment in the US or Cepheus
as it's known and they really look at
transactions that give rise to national
security concerns and we've already seen
quite a change of attitude particularly
around Chinese and investment and
concerns about widening up those
controls to take in more sorts of
transactions than just national security
because again if you go back to
president-elect Trump's interview
yesterday he's really big on reciprocity
and if a deal can't be done by a US
company in China you might think he's
not going to allow the Chinese to do
that deal here in here in the States
and of course the flipside a lot of
guess is that there's a danger of
retaliatory action I mean we've seen for
example state aid cases brought by the
EU against the likes of Apple and Amazon
is it possible that Trump might fire
with fire if we get more of those well
if he said if he's sincere about
imposing 35% tariffs on on the car
industry importing German cars into into
the States then we're going to be
looking for some fireworks I'd have
thought and briefly you mentioned China
there how worried are you about
protectionism between the US and China
well that treaty is is up for grabs
clearly president Trump had no great
fondness for rates during the election
period and the consequences between of
China
assai no American relationships I think
going to take quite some time to unwind